I wanted to do was focus attention on
the coming phase of the conflict now
well over a century old between the
United States and essentially
essentially the population of Central
America that's been an ongoing war an
unequal war the victims are all over
there
and there are many of them it entered a
new phase in the 1980s and it entered
another phase beginning on February 3rd
change in the character of this war and
I do want to focus on this coming phase
February 3rd I picked because that was
the day in which the Congress responding
to substantial popular dissidents
imposed certain limits on the what the
World Court called the unlawful use of
force by the United States and its
attack against Nicaragua I'll come back
to the background and details of that
but let me mention that February 3rd is
also opens a new phase in another war
that's been going on at the same time
and that's a war between the our
government and its population now that's
not unusual
typically States regard the general
population as an enemy that's normal the
task and role of the population is to be
apathetic obedient passive if it's
what's called a democracy they're
supposed to show up every once in a
while to ratify elite decisions but if
they get involved in anything beyond
that they're causing trouble and they
have to be controlled and they're an
enemy
now among elite groups there are
variation there are tactical variations
and the Reagan administration happens to
be at a rather extreme end of a spectrum
but it is it's not the spectrum hasn't
changed it's the old spectrum they just
happen to be extremists within that
spectrum and there are fear and
hostility of the general population is
also extreme also they happen to be
pretty open and frank about it so they
tell you if you bother to listen one of
the first things that the Reagan
administration did back near
ATS was to establish within the State
Department a thing called the
institution called the office for public
diplomacy which had the task of
controlling public debate and discussion
setting the framework for discussion so
it carried out operations like what they
called operation truth which is one that
we're will would love and it had about
as much relation to truth as you would
expect something to have with that title
it was exposed all of this was exposed
more or less last summer in the by one
of the few reporters who actually gave
serious coverage to the iran-contra
hearings by that I mean didn't just pick
up the release that was handed out but
actually bothered to look up the
documents Alfonso charty of the Miami
Herald back around July or August or so
he exposed the unit and now a study of
documents that had been released about
the office for public diplomacy and he
went to members of the Reagan
administration high administration
officials and asked them to explain you
know account for all of this and they
were quite frank and happy about it
they described the this brainwashing
operation as one of their most
spectacular successes and one which is
correct if you think about a lead
opinion was very successful in setting
the discussion and debate about Central
America and the coral in particular in
fact one high administration official
described the these operations to
chardee as the kind of operations you
would carry out an enemy territory now
that's a telling an accurate phrase from
the point of view of the administration
the population is enemy territory and
the people are inhabitants of enemy
territory and you got if you can't
control them by force you got to control
them by propaganda now again that's not
a position that's unique to this
administration it's a standard position
going into it later if you like it's
very it's long articulated in our
history back to the origins of the of
our society and it's very typical of
other societies as well but the Reagan
administration is at an extreme point
and they
they were very proud of their successes
in the war that they conducted an enemy
territory at home that is the
ideological war now if you can't control
the if you can't control the population
by force and you even and you can't even
control it by by propaganda the state is
faces of the women and at that only one
thing they can do in that case and that
is to go underground and in fact that's
just what happened during the 1980s
operation truths worked very well the
office of public diplomacy succeeded
very well among elites who basically
agreed with the policies anyhow but it
didn't work very well among the general
population in fact it worked very badly
the population is more dissident and
active today than any time in the last
generation
contrary to what you often hear there's
not much articulation of this because
the elites don't reflect it and Congress
is only a very weak reflection of it the
media virtually no reflection at all but
in the general population there's plenty
of activism and dissidents and you can
tell it and the Reagan administration
learned it very quickly
they were very quickly driven
underground they were driven underground
by the opposition the inhabitants of
enemy territory who were not going to
tolerate the actions that they intended
to carry out now clandestine activities
in any state are a pretty fair measure
of the level of popular dissidents open
violence open overt terrorism and
aggression are far more efficient than
clandestine terrorism they just work a
lot better and furthermore they don't
bear the risk of exposure which sort of
causes all kind of problems when it
occasionally happens so when a state
turns to clandestine terrorism
clandestine violence it's because it's
forced to and it's forced to by its own
population clandestine activities are
not a secret from anybody else what are
called covered operations are obviously
not a secret to the victims the kinds of
operations that were in there again so
it takes a the operations that were
partially exposed during the iran-contra
hearings plainly they weren't a secret
to the victims they weren't a secret to
the mercenary states who were enlisted
in the cause they weren't a secret to
shady businessmen like
you know Richard Secord and the rest up
to make a buck in fact they weren't even
a secret that Congress in the press if
you want to know the truth they were
just at a low a low enough level so they
could be suppressed the only people that
they were secret from was enemy
population the enemy territory at home
there they were a secret the general
population didn't know about them and
that's the point of seek of clandestine
operations clandestine operations are
always a in part a war against the
domestic enemy and when a state carries
out extensive clandestine operations
it's very much afraid of its domestic
enemy and that's what happened in the
1980s during the period of August 2
January August 87 to January 88 the
Reagan administration Congress and the
media so elites generally had a certain
task their task was to demolish the
Guatemala City of Courts to which they
were opposed and the Accords were
unacceptable to Washington therefore
they had to go well how do you do it
there were a number let me first notice
that there were a number of features of
the Accords which were completely
unacceptable in Washington the central
feature of the Accords was what the
simultaneity feature you look at the way
the Accords were structured they were
based on the idea that a number of
things have to happen simultaneously in
the various countries and so on
now that's unacceptable to the United
States for two reasons for one thing the
simultaneity requirement would plates
barriers in the way of the United States
attack against Nicaragua and that's
obviously unacceptable
if the because the United States intends
to continue the attack in one way or
another so that's out and on that
there's an elite consensus there's no
debate over this in the media or in
Congress with very marginal exceptions
the simultaneity condition has to go the
Accords must be interpreted so that they
applied to Nicaragua and Nicaragua alone
that's what that means and that was done
very effectively there been a number of
studies of the media that give the exact
numbers but anybody's been reading the
papers or watching the tube knows the
story the idea that there have to
a number of things happening at once is
unacceptable because it would place
barriers to the u.s. tack and since
that's unacceptable simultaneity
condition which is the core the accords
has to go there's another reason why the
simultaneity condition is unacceptable
it would place barriers on the US attack
against the populations of Guatemala El
Salvador and Honduras because the
Accords call for measures to preserve
liberty and security and freedom and you
know access to free expression and so on
and so forth a whole range of measures
which are completely unacceptable to the
United States and cannot be possibly be
carried out unless without structural
changes in those countries that would
take that would eliminate the whole
security apparatus which was designed
with the support of the United States in
the case of Guatemala and Honduras and
is and developed and imposed by the
United States in the case of El Salvador
designed precisely for the purpose of
preventing that to happen that it was
designed for the purpose of traumatizing
repressing torturing and killing if
necessary the domestic population so
that they won't cause any problems any
more those are the kinds of states where
you don't worry about propaganda you go
after the jugular if people start to
open their mouth and that's what we did
down there and plainly those measures
cannot be stopped there's no way for the
Accords to apply to the u.s. terror
States it's inconceivable they'd have to
undergo a radical internal
transformation
so therefore the simultaneity
requirement is unacceptable for that
reason alone now let me stress again
that there's an elite consensus on this
for example say take the matter of
freedom of the press you'll notice that
there has been no debate in the United
States no discussion in the United
States during this phase of the Accords
on freedom of the press say in El
Salvador in fact what we hear is there
we have freedom of the press and a
certain technical sense that's true that
is there's no law in El Salvador which
says you can't have an independent
newspaper you don't need a law there was
an independent press in El Salvador in
1980 when the United States moved in
turned it into a Nazi style terror State
there was a free press in fact there
were two independent newspapers not
leftist or anything like that mainstream
independent newspapers Lacroix Nakano
Independiente well they're not around
any longer in the case of they were
never censored because we hate
censorship in the case of one of those
newspapers what happened is that the
u.s. runs security forces surrounded the
office with tanks destroyed it drove the
editor out of the country with
assassination threats after several
assassination attempts and took care of
one of them in the case of the other one
the our security forces there are forces
remember our security forces picked up
the editor and another journalist in a
in a restaurant in San Salvador took him
outside cut him to pieces with the
machete and left them in a ditch
somewhere the rest of them that took
care of the second newspaper so there's
no more problem of freedom of the press
in El Salvador and you'll notice that
nobody none of these sudden libertarians
who are so concerned about freedom of
the press have called for a reopening of
an independent press in El Salvador
nobody ever heard the words la cronic o
el Independiente you hear about La
Prensa including many lies but nobody
hears about freedom that of course
nothing remotely like this ever happened
in Nicaragua but you never hear a word
about freedom of the press and in El
Salvador in fact these events that these
two newspapers to be precise there were
three references to what I've just
described in the entire 1980s in the New
York Times so you can't claim that you
don't have a free press here but it was
so you know if you're really a scholar
and you got a terrific memory you can
remember that something unpleasant
happened there but it's certainly not an
issue
we don't look into the question will
nobody calls for freedom of the press
and El Salvador and for two very good
reasons for one thing Washington the
office of public diplomacy has ordered
us that that topic is off the agenda
we're not supposed to talk about that so
and therefore being loyal cowards we
naturally obey so that's one reason the
other reason is that the call for a free
press in El Salvador would be ridiculous
you can't have a free press in El
Salvador without first dismantling the
whole terror system that the United
States installed precisely to ensure
that you can't have things like a free
press or for that matter Bible study
groups that might turn into peasant
self-help groups and in fact all the
developments that cause Washington to
unleash the terror a poetics so the
sense is absurd to ask for a free press
I guess there's no point in doing so in
any event no one asks about it
meanwhile I should say in Nicaragua
nothing remotely comparable has happened
the opposition claims harassment and of
course it always hits the front pages of
the newspapers but they're not expecting
to be murdered or tortured and this
opposition is extreme it's the kind of
opposition which has never survived
didn't have been a Western democracy in
times of crisis la prensa for example
and the groups around it are openly
support the u.s. attack against
nicaragua nothing secret about it I just
had the I guess I'm not sure it's happy
experience but experience of reading
three months worth of La Prensa I must
be the only person outside the CIA who
actually has all of La Prensa since the
time was opened in my office at home and
it's just openly Pro contra doesn't even
hide it no it's oh it's simply a US
government disinformation or Oregon I
mean to allow the journal to publish
it's as if in the United States during
the second world war the media were
largely dominated by Japanese fascist
journals calling for the overthrow of
the US government and the liberation of
you know the territories in the Pacific
from the racist murders in the United
States or something like that I mean
such things are inconceivable you know
it never happened in the West and the
same is true of what we call the
opposition which openly identifies with
the u.s. attack against Nicaragua and
regards the US is there only basic
political support well that they they do
get harassed and you know they get
censured and that sort of thing they
don't get murdered in El Salvador
there's nothing even remotely similar in
some way the press knows all of this but
will never report any of it
inconceivable that they report these
things though every journalist in
Managua and sentsov Adorno's it but
again nobody is talking about the
application of the terms of the Accords
which would permit the opposition even a
mild opposition to function nobody's
talking about those conditions in El
Salvador that's off
agenda and in general all the Sentinel
community requirements are unacceptable
because they would require the
dismantling of the terror apparatus that
the United States took such pains to
impose and still supports now another
feature of the Accords that's
unacceptable was international
verification the Accords had in them a
provision for verification and
international verification commission
which included the five Central American
countries the Latin American democracies
the Contador countries the OAS the
Organization of American States in the
United Nations well plainly that's
unacceptable essentially for the reasons
I just mentioned international
verification would put barriers in the
way of the US attack against Nicaragua
and the u.s. attack against the
populations of El Salvador Guatemala and
Honduras via the terrorist apparatus the
military regimes which were either
imposed or supported for that purpose so
that's unacceptable another reason why
international verification is
unacceptable to the United States is
that the Latin American country is
though dependent of course on the United
States after all we are the 800-pound
gorilla they're dependent on the United
States and there are limits beyond which
they can go nevertheless they have a
degree of independence they have a
degree of independence and therefore
they're not allowed in at all in fact
nobody with the degree of independence
from the master of the hemisphere is
allowed in so plainly international
verification has to go and in fact the
demolition job on the accords was
completed by January by January the
simultaneity condition was thrown out
international verification was
terminated and in fact nothing remains
of the Accords they are finished they're
part of ancient history nothing remains
of the Guatemala City of course the
press may talk about the RAS Accords and
so on but either they're lying
consciously or else they're unwilling to
bother to look the fact of the matter is
there is nothing left of those Accords
what is left is of
version of the Accords written in
Washington and transmitted by the press
and accepted by Congress and that
version says Nicaragua has to exceed two
arbitrary demands stated by the United
States governor whatever they happen to
be
that's the Accords and that's all there
is left though there's nothing left of
the original text well what were the
means used to destroy the Accords this
is a very successful demolition job what
were the means used well there were two
kinds there were military means and
there were ideological means you might
say the military means were first of all
and most important the intensification
of the CIA supply flags that was the
most important event that happened
during August to Dan uary as I mentioned
the supply flights which of course
illegal to start with were sharply
intensified to about two to three a day
and also US surveillance flights which
they were very expensive surveillance
apparatus although fanciest sr-71s and
u2's and satellites and spy ships off
the coast and so on are carrying out
intensive surveillance of Nicaragua and
that was extended to now both of those
operations are significant the supply
flights are crucial in fact critical
because as is recognized on all sides of
this debate the Contras the proxy army
are not guerrillas they have no remote
relation to guerrillas the KGB doesn't
fly two to three supply flights a day
and the El Salvador to keep the
guerrillas in the field
and nobody's talking about sending
humanitarian aid to the guerrillas you
don't have to because they're part of
the country they're rooted in the
country they fight inside their own
country they've got their own network of
support in fact the reason for us terror
in El Salvador has been to try to
destroy that base of support but they
don't need supplies they don't have to
give it to the countries on the other
hand have to get everything from food to
fancy communication equipment to boots
to arms and so on because they're not
part of the country they're a foreign
implant that's what it means to sit in
fact you nobody nobody really denies
this is not a topic for debate you know
the Reagan administration the first ones
to tell you that this force is going to
unless we continue to provide them with
arms and supplies the meaning of that
which they don't bother to tell you in
the press but you can figure it out the
meaning of that is they're not
guerrillas because nobody does this for
guerrillas and in fact that's written
into the Accords ice under well
understood in Central America you take a
look at the actual wording of the
Accords and they say that an the
indispensable element for peace in the
region is an end to any form of support
and then they mention military
logistical propaganda or whatever to two
kinds of groups namely irregular forces
and insurrections movements now the
distinction for that is that the
irregular force of the country's foreign
for foreign organised forces attacking
some country the insurrectionist
movement our movements our indigenous
guerrillas and the indispensable element
of the Accords is the termination of any
form of support for them any form
logistical or whatever and of course the
as a corollary the use of one country is
a territory for foreign Sep
insurrectionist movement for irregular
forces attacking another in January the
International Commission the
verification Commission gave published
its report now that was plainly the most
important thing that happened in January
here's this Commission made up of the
five Central American countries and the
Latin American democracies and OAS and
UN had investigated all the countries
they finally came out with the report
now we can finally get an independent
objective assessment of the compliance
with the with the Guatemala City accords
well it was mentioned in the New York
Times we have a free press it got
actually one sentence in the New York
Times buried in an article by James
Lemoine in which he stated that the
conference that the Commission broke up
in this agreement well in fact its
report was unanimously accepted but that
was the total description in the news
report on January 14th when 15 report
was issued on the 14th other here and
there you could find this cargo Tribune
actually covered it in this case but
there was very little coverage well and
you can see why the conclusions of the
Commission were just not useful for
ideological warfare why
first of all the Commission denounced
the United States its singled out the
United States and the United States
alone for condemnation because the
United States had undermined the
indispensable element for peace in the
region
by continuing its support for the
irregular forces attacking Nicaragua
Honduras and in fact from Costa Rica and
that that's the central condemnation in
the Accords well plainly that's useless
now the Commission went on to say that
they couldn't provide detailed comments
on the particular countries of the
region and the reason for that was that
three countries objected El Salvador
Guatemala and Honduras the three u.s.
terror states would not permit a
description you can figure out for
yourselves what the description would
have been and but the US wouldn't allow
it
through its clients it blocked any
description of the however they did
carry out a press conference in Costa
Rica and there the delegates discussed
this at Latin American representatives
spoke openly at the press conferences of
what they called they said they were
shocked by the attitude of paitent fear
in the faces of opposition people and
trade unionists in El Salvador in
Guatemala the two u.s. terror States
well claimed there's no point in
reporting that the Commission also
praised Nicaragua for what they called
concrete steps towards democratization
despite the ongoing us aggression well
it's plainly useless in fact none of
this is useful for ideological warfare
so therefore it didn't happen and the
reporting is virtually zero in the New
York Times which is the most important
newspaper worse than zero one sentence
which was a lie the commission plainly
had to be disbanded and the u.s. simply
insisted that it be disbanded the main
US client in the region Jose Napoleon
Duarte who is a Democrat by definition
because he follows us orders it's also
one of the worst murderers in the
history of Latin America and he's
reviled and be tested throughout Latin
America for this region but here he's
very highly praised he said with some
insight I think that it wasn't really
necessary to have an International
Commission of verification because he
said the press would suffice
for verification that's quite right that
provides that expresses a real insight
into the workings of the press well that
took care of the international
verification Commission so one element
of the course the basic element of
course is gone no more international
supervision and recognizing that the
powerful make the rules and the weak
just obey Nicaraguan president Ortega
then announced that Nicaragua would
adhere to the conditions of the Accords
alone